[Music]
hey guys dimitri pascal oda here for the
score esports unfortunately call and
triggered a claymore trying to rush the
objective and isn't around to do this
week's top ten
rest assured though he's in recovery and
we back in fighting form in time for
next week's list now let's talk about
ash whether you love her or hate her ash
is one of Rainbow six siege his most
iconic operators and even though people
are still crying over one of her a cogs
being taken away her fragging power and
highlight-reel potential have hardly
cooled off she tries to turn the corner
next I want a trade at the server door
goes for two this is g36 cutting another
one for Nick's so we thought this would
be a great time to show you what we
think are the top ten nuttiest ash plays
in Rainbow six siege coming in at number
10 is none other than g2 eSports is
Kanto Roquette II during a season 9 Pro
League match against Team empire Empire
looked to be in a great position to take
the round with the Finn left against
three defenders and the defuser left to
be collected across the map but then
contour Ketty happened shepard cuts down
Fabi and leaving just can't tell
roquette II say goodbye to Scyther the
Finn's gonna continue to go on as ash
he's got joystick and Shepard to find
shooting Kanto does not hold the defuser
it's gonna have to go fetch it it's over
by the double panels inside of CEO this
is right for opportunity but the smoke
is smart he'll just play from below far
away they are nobody is really in
position right now to be able to take
Kanto down he's gonna be exposed for
another four three two one seconds and
then oh he's got some money so he takes
out choice Nick and all the pings right
now on to Shepard low on HP Shepard
might be blind oh what a great shot on
tanto who bought first caught John
banana
he'll get Shepard say bye bye and g2
will move on to match point
all because a wonderful one on three
from Kanto
in their favor I cannot believe it
coming in at number nine is this Ash
play from supremacist B boo at the 2018
six Invitational up against ya gaming
the Frenchman quickly found himself
cornered and outnumbered four-to-one but
with just about 20 seconds left on the
clock
Bebo showed us that he could do the
impossible with time to spare
they're all falling down you and I was
one more leaving one out live bibo
fighting for his life on the ass here
pulls out the fight center takes it babe
or you gave me four years in a row and
yeah completely falling down supremacy
are still alive
wow that was a heck of a fight our
number 8 play comes courtesy of fanatics
R is Raz from a match in the 2019 six
invitational against faze clan the
Aussies were ahead by four rounds on the
Brazilians map pic and if that wasn't
tilting enough the ash single-handedly
extended that lead without taking a
single point of damage file this one
under just ash things stairs ere we go
looks for the opportunity and succeeds
upon it cameraman goes down as R is Raz
finally gets a kill oh my goodness what
a throw as I believe it who was that up
on top was that magnet but we are gonna
see a map get himself in to engage me
gotta be careful with the hope holes
blown into the for as R is wrath now
found eight third kill in this round
really going on a tear at this point
only moringa and yuna left and he's got
his aids if he wants to try and go for
it and see the throat moving it now
before they actually pushed the site it
works there's the fourth from RIS rise
let's see do we get the ACE and I think
we do rizz rad shutting it all down
beautiful stuff from him making his
second appearance on this list is g2
eSports is contourer Ketty this time
with a disgusting Ashe way from the pro
league season 8 semi-finals sure g2 s
finished duo found themselves on the
wrong side of a 2 V 4 against fnatic
but leave it to Kanto to turn things
around landing a beautiful triple kill
before winning the round fine
4v2 advantage of course here for fnatic
put the headshots been found lusty will
get dropped flashbang thrown in though
from the deep top ripped up hell's basis
is he finally gonna get dropped does he
find the head in the back - maestro damn
it Chuck dr. akane he threads the needle
neophyte Oh laughs alive as this house
fanatic go down a thundering roar this
is absolutely insane can't Erick any
showing why is the Kerry rocket but
they're not done just yet the number six
play in our list ceaseless stream
eSports is uno Meister put on a show at
the 2019 six Invitational qualifiers
taking on team empire uno was left in a
post plant situation with three enemies
left on the retake but with excellent
use of cover the ash was able to isolate
the fights against the defenders and
extend her team's lead but shockwave
with a great kill 1 - Higgs will try and
get another one easily trade it out my
you know it's all down to him and a 1v2
post blunt he has the punt down and he
has the kills he gets another Shepard I
don't know were the three came to finish
it up oh my god blue stream take rounder
before but the Skinner that's even just
off the back of you know oh my god
coming in at the number 5 spot is this
show-stopping ash performance from space
station gaming's rampage during season 9
of pro league in this insane match
against team reciprocity the ash player
caught absolute fire you know it was it
is what they did last time rampy adding
more kills lucky number 13 there you go
or so go a nice shot from rampy again 14
kills in total I'll take down right row
at the castle and the Jager and another
one rant B with a three Kayla round
skies instantly flicked to the head this
ramp e upstairs looking for another kill
find them there you go for K for rampy
beautiful battle play here and with 22
kills by the end of the map we just
couldn't choose one single play so
here's this one v3 clutch from the
following round that put his team on
match
rampe you're moving into blue a daggers
were covered the body is in there but a
losses teammate Mark will find the
colony Jaeger no quick brush from rampy
I'll take one it's still 200 live retro
and mark the shark 15 seconds up from
the clock is I'll find one on the ager
the last one alive is still upstairs
retro as far we'll be spreading from
retro he's still in sunrise bar he'll
peek in does the castle will lose the
fighter let be again he'll clutch it
every single time on an absolute monster
coming in at the number 4 spot on our
list is liquids nest from the Pro League
season 7 quarterfinals in true Ashe main
fashion nest found two quick kills
against fnatic less than a minute into
the round and about a minute later he
closed it out with this filthy ace a
shot from the shotgun will push the
Jaeger out in l sex cake going for a
shot nest manages to take out back in
and it's another whole nest and sexy
cake being able to push in together and
you've at least salvaged the losses that
you have used to very low utility
operators nest he's gonna get his third
kill on the lusty you can see the shield
will attack aces he goes to shoot his
nitro cell and this is gonna come down a
fourth Furness I feel like we just saw a
video where Ness was able to kill them
all and an ace furnace what a round for
the ash player to keep his team in it
all five oh my my and not overtime quite
yet still match point for fnatic but
liquid able to counter punch after
fnatic was able to open up such a lead
up the number three spot on our list
goes to just one of the many highlight
worthy place from Penghu at the pro
league year to season two semi finals
the Dane was looking to rally back from
a poor Game one performance against team
font and well he did just that there oh
oh here we go
Pangu is fresh and finally gets the kill
Pangu is just gonna be waiting around
they don't have to peek this too much
this guy wait until the Jets and the
crossfire and peggle gets what
and bangle codes this is the panga we
know that that's the pay you on actually
justifies that pick so nicely done by
Penghu showing why he's playing it that
way
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
this lethal ash sequence courtesy of
Team Empire's joystick during the
Challenger League season a tu final now
this Russian ash main is currently one
of the best in the world and this should
show you exactly why joystick yeah the
highlight fragging player yeah so if
there's one player to take a look at on
Team Empire its joystick allowing uno to
retake tower is a mistake but joystick
will correct that even for a highlight
frag players such as uno and joystick
will get yet another one that's the
three kills in this first round this
either will get one more as he opens up
the site and it's all on the shot day of
course the world champion in the back of
watching the armory call it the corridor
and loser will go down from Sheppard
good peek from shocked at by choice take
Wow
now you might be thinking four kills in
the opening round is pretty impressive
but joystick manages to one-up himself
two rounds later joystick though has the
drop already open it will cut off the
rotation all these can be opened on the
Havanna thrown in the beautiful shot day
what are you doing Oh No what a mistake
from the world champion himself Goffe
will refract onto Garza
Zeca but he gets downed by joystick and
a pistol kill for joystick holy what is
going on it's all up to boot see now
he's even it out someone to one on - but
joystick once more shutting down boon
see and team Empire take the round that
was a choice to kiss taking the top spot
on our list is yet another solo ash
clutch from Kanto riccati if there's
anything that this play teaches us it's
that a 1v3 means absolutely nothing when
you're up
against a player like Kanto good and
yellowness vanquished leaving Kanto
riccati to deal with the three remaining
members of phase and very quickly he
will reduce it to two with maringá and
yuna but he's gonna give himself easy
access in towards service and this is a
very winnable position with that r4c in
the hands of the finn i need to grab the
defuser it's quite a ways away and
moringa crowed with the shotgun blast
Kanto around the corner silencing the
crowd and g2 up for two - absolutely
insane aim there from cancer a Kenny the
transfer as clean as it gets
well guys I don't know about you but
that list was hard to watch Ashe means
are absolutely intolerable but if you
want to see your operator get the top
ten treatment head to the comments and
let us know whether it be glass castle
even the Lord Himself don't forget to
like the video subscribe to our channel
we'll see you next week thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button